hemos visto que en los últimos vídeos
tomamos una distribución loca o también
puede ser una distribución normal pero
no es necesario que tengan una
distribución normal digamos que tenemos
esta distribución loca como estoy
dibujando acá y hemos visto varias veces
que tomamos muestras de esta
distribución toda loca digamos que vamos
a tomar que m el número de muestras es
igual a 10 así que tomamos 10 instancias
de esta variable aleatoria sacamos su
promedio y dibujamos nuestro promedio al
dibujar el promedio tenemos una
instancia acá y hacemos esto una y otra
vez obtenemos 10 muestras de esa
variable aleatoria sacamos su promedio
la dibujamos y eventualmente cuando
hacemos esto muchas pero muchas veces en
teoría un número infinito de veces vamos
a aproximarnos a la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra con n
igual a 10 no va a ser una distribución
normal perfecta pero va a ser bastante
aproximada sería perfecta solo si m
fuera igual a infinito así que
eventualmente todas nuestras muestras
van a seguir graficando
y acumulándose más o menos así y
eventualmente se tendrá algo que luce
más o menos así y del vídeo anterior
vimos que bueno si queremos hacerlo de
nuevo pero esta vez con m igual
a 20 la distribución que vamos a obtener
va a ser mucho más normal y en futuros
vídeos veremos más a detalle los
conceptos de sesgo y curtósis así pues
esta distribución con en e igual a 20 va
a ser mucho más normal y algo mucho más
interesante es que va a tener una
desviación estándar bastante más pequeña
digamos que la media de esta variable
aleatoria es un 165 y la media aquí
también va a ser 5 la media de la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra también va a ser 5 y aquí no
importa cuál sea el valor de n esta
media de la muestra también va a ser 5
pero nuestra descripción estándar va a
ser mucho más pequeña que cualquiera de
las dos anteriores así que puede lucir
más o menos así si lo hiciéramos con una
muestra todavía más grande
vamos a ponerle un color diferente
una muestra con n igual a 100 lo que
vamos a tener es algo que se acerca
todavía un más a una distribución normal
tomamos 100 muestras de esta
distribución las promediamos y las
dibujamos y así lo seguimos haciendo y
si lo seguimos haciendo lo que vamos a
tener es algo que es aún más normal que
las anteriores mucho más cercano a una
verdadera distribución normal pero lo
más obvio a la vista es que va a tener
una desviación estándar todavía más
pequeña por lo que va a tener una
desviación estándar mucho mucho más
pequeña se va a ver algo más o menos así
y veremos cómo se hace esto en una
aplicación de simulación que veremos en
el siguiente vídeo oa lo mejor después
en este mismo vídeo así que dos cosas
suceden conforme aumentamos el número de
muestras dos cosas suceden una nos
volvemos más normales y nuestra
desviación estándar se hace más pequeña
así que la pregunta que surge es existe
alguna fórmula si yo sé que la
desviación estándar estas medias
reacciones están de mi función de
distribución de probabilidad original y
esta es la media
conozco la desviación estándar y conozco
n que va a estar cambiando conforme yo
vaya aumentando el número de muestras si
yo conozco la división estándar y
conozco n a lo mejor también conozco la
varianza ya que es la desviación
estándar al cuadrado si no recuerdan
esto pueden realizar los vídeos
anteriores de estadística pero si yo
conozco la varianza de mi distribución
original y si yo conozco cuál es mi n
cuantas muestras voy a tomar cada vez
que haga un promedio de ellas para poder
graficar las en la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra habrá
alguna manera de predecir cuál será la
media de estas distribuciones pero cuál
será la desviación estándar de estas dos
distribuciones y para no confundirnos
vamos a hablar mejor de la varianza ya
que podemos encontrar la desviación
estándar a partir de ésta esta es la
varianza de nuestra distribución
original
ahora para mostrar que esta es la
varianza de nuestra distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra lo
escribí aquí esa es la varianza de
nuestra media la media de nuestra
muestra recordemos que esta es nuestra
media verdadera esta letra muy griega es
la media real es igual a la media
mientras que la equis con la línea
encima de nuestra media de la muestra lo
que aquí estamos diciendo es que si aquí
tenemos la varianza de nuestra medida de
la muestra ésta va a ser una
distribución verdadera si nosotros
conociéramos de antemano esta
distribución ésta tendría una varianza
ésta tiene una media y esa también es
otra media si hacemos bien nuestra
notación ésta va a ser la media de la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra
así que esta es la media de nuestras
medias
y resulta que son las mismas esta es la
media también de nuestras muestras y
también va a ser lo mismo el punto de
este vídeo se encontra si hay alguna
manera de calcular esta varianza
conociendo la varianza de nuestra
distribución original y el número de
elementos de la muestra y pues que creen
resulta que si la hay no voy a
desarrollar la prueba aquí pero les voy
a dar la intuición de ello ya que
ustedes saben que por cada prueba que se
hace si ustedes toman 100 muestras es
mucho más probable que ustedes lleguen a
la media verdadera que si tienen una n
de 2 o de 5 es muy poco probable que
ustedes puedan llegar a esta media así
que yo creo que ustedes intuyen que el
llegar a la media es inversamente
proporcional al tamaño de la muestra n
mientras más grande sea nuestra n más
pequeña será la desviación estándar y
resulta que esto es muy sencillo no les
voy a hacer la prueba formal sino les
voy a dar el conocimiento para que
ustedes lo puedan usar siempre en
estadística dudó en sí darles primero la
definición formal o darles
el conocimiento más práctico pero
siempre me decido por darles el
conocimiento práctico ya que es lo que
más se usa las pruebas experimentales
creo que es lo que necesitan en esos
momentos ya habrá tiempo más adelante
para las definiciones formales resulta
que la varianza de la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra va a
ser igual a la varianza de la
distribución original
esta beca dividida entre n que más
sencillo puede haber si esto de que
arriba tiene una varianza de 20 me acabo
de inventar este número
y en nuestra n también es igual a 20
entonces la varianza de la distribución
de muestreo de la media de la muestra
para una n igual a 20 y con esta
variante de 2020 entre 20 pues va a ser
igual a 1
así que nuestra varianza es igual a 20
entre 20 igual a 1
esa es la varianza de distribución
original y ésta va a ser la varianza de
la media de la muestra y nuestra
desviación estándar va a ser la raíz
cuadrada de esto la raíz cuadrada de 1
queda en 1 así que nuestra fórmula
quedaría así sacamos la raíz cuadrada en
ambos lados y nos queda que la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de muestreo de la media de la muestra
que normalmente se le llama a la
desviación estándar de la media también
se le conoce y esto lo voy a escribir
acá el error estándar de la media
estándar
de la media todas estas cosas que acabo
de mencionar significan la desviación
estándar de la distribución de muestreo
de la media de la muestra sé que esto es
un poco confuso ya que siempre usa las
palabras media y muestra lo bueno de
tener el vídeo es que ustedes se pueden
poner pausa en cualquier momento para
darse un momento y comprender bien de lo
que les estoy hablando lo importante es
que si sacamos la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados de esta ecuación nos quedará que
la desviación estándar de la
distribución de muestreo de la media de
la muestra va a ser igual a la
desviación estándar de nuestra
distribución original dividida entre la
raíz cuadrada de n aquí obtuve la raíz
cuadrada en el numerador y denominador
personalmente prefiero recordar esta
fórmula de acá que esta otra y a partir
de esta deducir la de abajo ya que es
mucho más directo para mí recordar lo
que es la varianza y que es igual a la
varianza entre el número de las muestras
entre m así que aquí la desviación
estándar cuando en es igual a 1 la
desviación estándar de la distribución
de muestreo de la media de la muestra es
igual a 1 y aquí cuando en es igual a
100 nuestra varianza de la distribución
de muestra
media de la muestra o la varianza de la
media va a ser igual a 20 que es la
varianza de aquí arriba de la original
entre 100
esto es igual a un quinto la desviación
estándar de nuevo de la distribución de
muestreo de la media de la muestra o el
error estándar de la media va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de un quinto
igual a 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de 5
así que esta parte de acá va a ser menos
de un medio en la desviación estándar en
comparación de la de quique la
desviación estándar es igual a 1 y como
pueden ver es mucho más delgada y
ustedes pueden decirme bueno mira tú me
has dado una fórmula pero no
necesariamente tengo por qué creer bueno
vamos a ver si podemos probar esto de
manera práctica y para eso vamos a usar
una simulación vamos a cambiar esta
distribución vamos a hacer un poco más
loca así y así esta es mi nueva
distribución y vamos a tomar una m que
sea fácil de encontrar su raíz cuadrada
vamos a tomar una n de 16 y otra m de 25
y vamos a hacer 10.000 muestras o 10 mil
intentos tomamos nuestros 16 muestras
hacemos el promedio lo dibujamos aquí y
esto lo repetimos 10.000 veces aquí
abajo vamos a tomar 25 muestras las
prometíamos y las gráficas vamos a hacer
una animación simplemente para recordar
cómo es esto aquí están 16 muestras se
promedia y aquí se grafica otras 25
muestras se promedian y geográfica si yo
repito esto 10.000 veces que es lo que
voy a obtener aquí este resultado
visualmente se pueden dar cuenta que
cuando la n es mayor la desviación
estándar es más chica aquí está más
delgadito pero bueno vamos a escribir
esto a ver si nos podemos acordar
en esta distribución estándar que acabo
de hacer mi desviación estándar es de
9.3 voy a acordarme de esto la
distribución estándar original es 9.3 la
desviación estándar de aquí es de 2.33 y
la desviación estándar de aquí abajo es
de 1.87 vamos a ver si podemos confirmar
esta fórmula que les comenté hace un
momento vamos a quitar esto de la
pantalla por un momento y acordarnos de
los valores aquí vamos a hacer espacio
en la prueba que acabamos de hacer de mi
distribución todo lo que tenía una
desviación estándar de 9.3
cuando m es igual a 16
n igual a 16
cuando hicimos muchas pruebas cuando
tuvimos la desviación estándar de la
distribución de muestra de la media de
la muestra o la desviación estándar del
error experimentalmente determinamos que
estas desviaciones de 2.33 y cuando ven
es igual a 25 lo ponemos en otro color
tenemos que el error estándar de la
media es igual a 1.87 y recordemos
nuestra fórmula sabemos que la varianza
de la media o el error estándar o la
varianza de la distribución de muestreo
de la media de la muestra es igual a la
varianza de nuestra distribución
original dividida entre m sacamos la
raíz cuadrada en ambos lados de la
ecuación y nos queda el error estándar
de la media es igual a la decisión
estándar de la distribución original
dividida entre la raíz cuadrada de n
sustituimos estos valores para cuando en
es igual a 16 vamos a hacer este caso
9.3 entre la raíz cuadrada de 16 que es
44 por 4 16
9.64 cuál va a ser 9.3 dividido entre 4
usamos nuestra confiable calculadora
y vamos a tener
9.3
/ raíz cuadrada de 4 por ejemplo es
cuadrada de 16 que es cuatro nos queda
2.32 5 y lo redondeamos a 2.32 esto es
igual a 2.32
lo que es muy cercano a él 2.33 este que
obtuvimos realizando 10 mil muestras
igual podríamos ver qué pasa con esto si
hacemos 100.000 muestras o doscientas
mil muestras ahora vamos a ver este otro
aquí tenemos un 9.3 bueno vamos a
dividir esto y hacer espacio tomamos
nuestra desviación estándar de la
distribución original es esta fórmula de
aquí que nuestro error estándar debe ser
igual a la desviación estándar de la
distribución original 9.3 entre la raíz
cuadrada de n en este caso en es igual a
25 su raíz cuadrada de 55 por 5 25 así
que esto es igual a 9.3 entre 5 y debe
acercarse el valor al 1.87 vamos a ver
con nuestra calculadora cuál es el
resultado así que la sacamos de nuevo
ahora tomo
9.3 /
5 igual a 1.86 que es bastante cercano a
1.87 que tenemos acá
esto es igual a
y 1.86 1.86 como pueden ver lo que
obtuvimos de forma experimental es casi
exactamente y esto es después de usar
10.000 muestras a lo que nos da el
resultado teórico si hiciéramos otras 10
mil muestras bueno quizás no llegue al
número exacto pero es bastante bastante
cercano al que obtenemos con la fórmula
así que la varianza de la distribución
de muestreo de la media de la muestra va
a ser igual a la varianza de la
distribución original no importa qué tan
loca sea está dividida entre el número
de las muestras el número de las
muestras de las que se toma un promedio
y en algunos momentos esto puede ser
confuso ya que están tomando muestras de
promedios de muestras así que se puede
confundir si es el número de la muestra
o el número de veces que estoy tomando
el promedio de estas muestras por lo que
nunca está de más hacer la aclaración
normalmente cuando hablamos del tamaño
de la muestra nos referimos a n
al menos en mi mente cuando yo estoy
pensando en pruebas si yo tomo viene
igual a 16 y obtengo un promedio esa es
una prueba y la gráfico lo hago
nuevamente y hacemos otra prueba y así
una y otra y otra vez pero bueno espero
que esto les haya aclarado el concepto y
que ahora comprendan cómo obtener el
error estándar de la media